[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en 1985 Argentina creó el pueblo del
chaltén cerca de la frontera con chile
para poner freno a una disputa
territorial con el vecino país poco a
poco fue creciendo Y convirtiéndose en
capital Nacional del trekking y un
atractivo global para turistas amantes
en la naturaleza y las montañas y
también en una meca de la escalada
mundial la aldea creció a tal magnitud
que los terrenos se agotaron y gran
parte de sus habitantes hoy viven en una
situación precaria y en condiciones de
hacinamiento estamos con Natalia ocoso
nuestro corresponsal en Argentina y
autor de este reporteros les saludo
natalio Cómo vive este lugar que nació
por decisión burocrática se consolidó
por su propio valor y belleza y hoy está
el límite de su capacidad
primero iba muy poca gente era muy
difícil llegar era un lugar remoto con
muy pocos recursos con muy pocos
servicios poco a poco fue ganando
servicios Se fue haciendo un lugar muy
atractivo para el turismo primero un
turismo más de aventura sobre todo para
para ser caminatas y paseos por la
montaña trekking de hecho es la capital
Nacional del trekking hoy en día en
Argentina el chaltén en los años 2000
llegó una vía asfáltica Así es mucho más
fácil llegar en vehículo desde una
localidad cercana al calafate a donde se
llega en avión y eso ha incrementado aún
más el turismo eso ha generado muchísima
presión sobre la infraestructura
habitacional del pueblo y sobre los
servicios urbanos que le presta a sus
visitantes y a sus habitantes tiene
serias dificultades de vivienda y de
terreno porque fue emplazado sobre una
cantidad de hectáreas que le cedió el
parque nacional que existe allí al
pueblo pero está rodeado de Parque
Nacional
nacional y a menos que le cedan más
hectáreas el pueblo no tiene hacia dónde
crecer esa presión está siendo muy
difícil la vida para Quienes son locales
para quienes quieren instalarse y vivir
allí
gracias natalio Ya volvemos con usted
aquí la historia
[Música]
ama la montaña de hecho trabaja en ella
como brigadista pero en este día
simplemente Está disfrutando es como un
lugar que que siento que me ofrece
muchísimos muchísimos regalos
los senderos que recorre Marian
pertenecen a este lugar único la zona
norte del Parque Nacional los glaciares
en la Patagonia Argentina para
escaladores Y Amantes del senderismo
Este es un lugar de peregrinación un
paraíso de montaña
Los visitantes se alojan en el pueblo
del chaltén que se encuentra en el valle
que Mira hacia este icónico cordón
montañoso en el chaltén vio en más de
2.000 habitantes a los que se suman en
temporada alta de octubre a marzo 1500
trabajadores golondrina y una ocupación
de por lo menos 4000 plazas turísticas
con esta cantidad de visitantes en el
chaltén hay trabajo hay fuentes de
ingreso sin embargo escasea algo
esencial la vivienda
Marian por ejemplo Hace dos años que
vive en esta casilla
esta es mi cocina con el hornito Bueno
Este es como el espacio donde hacemos
casi todo porque acá nos nos sentamos a
desayunar a pintar a bailar a hacer lo
que
[Música]
el día a día
Esta es la estufa que tengo que con esta
calentamos la la casita y
bueno instrumentos los instrumentos
tienen un este espacio propio que es ahí
acá allá en toda la casa de instrumentos
[Música]
Yo quisiera
para quemar todos mis males
Y en silencio me comiera mis basuras
terrenales tengo todo lo que lo básico
más bueno viviendo con una niña y todo
es está lejos de ser una vivienda
adecuada como se dice legalmente a una
vivienda digna y aún así las presiones
habitacionales del chaltén podrían hacer
que tenga que dejar el pueblo
siento que tengo raíces muy firmes acá
que hago como un gran aporte a la
comunidad y que la comunidad me aporta
un montón a mí la montaña que este lugar
ya es parte
constitutiva de mi identidad y de quién
soy y
sería muy triste
[Risas]
es duro es y creo que chaltén está
perdiendo grandes valores
el chaltén se fundó en 1985 en el
contexto de una disputa territorial con
chile la idea del gobierno de Entonces
era demostrar que al estar habitada por
argentinos la zona era indiscutiblemente
de este país para establecer el pueblo
el parque nacional los glaciares que
tiene más de 725.000 hectáreas se dio
135 de ellas los terrenos del chaltén se
fueron entregando a quienes llegaban a
habitar el lugar pero prácticamente no
hay más
Ricardo Sánchez se mudó al chaltén
Algunos años después de la fundación en
yo llegué con un
Renault 12 modelo 76 después lo tuve que
cambiar pues y acá el
era todo ripio y no aguantaba el autito
lo cambié por una camioneta pero éramos
muy pocos los vehículos aparte no había
combustible no había gas era todo muy
muy primitivo no
hoy Ricardo Sánchez es uno de los
concejales del pueblo desde ese rol
analiza los impactos de la
transformación que tuvo el lugar desde
su llegada hubo un desbalance de
crecimiento a partir del 2000 este
pueblo comenzó a crecer crecer crecer y
no se fue acompañando con el suministro
de servicios públicos hacia ese
crecimiento siempre estamos por atrás de
esta situación tratando de paliarlo pero
nunca tenemos solución definitiva
Entonces estamos con problemas de agua
de procesamiento de líquidos cloacales
de generación de Electricidad no están
en una forma óptima el gas estamos
siempre al límite
la planta de procesamiento de desechos
cloacales que existen en el chaltén es
insuficiente para el tamaño del pueblo
me vas preparando por favor
para determinar el impacto que esto
puede tener un grupo de habitantes
estableció el proyecto donde nacen las
aguas con esta zona multiparamétrica
podemos medir las características
fisicoquímicas del agua vamos a medir la
temperatura el pH la conductividad y los
sólidos totales y sueltos que es una
caracterización básica de un curso de
agua regularmente realizan mediciones de
la composición del agua en la zona y
analizan su microbiología todavía no han
obtenido resultados concluyentes Pero
existe la sospecha de que los efluentes
pueden estar afectando las aguas del río
seguramente contaminación fecal porque
la planta de tratamiento de las aguas
no tienen la capacidad para sanear a las
aguas del chaltén
la cuestión de la salud no tiene Sólo
que ver con la preservación de recursos
como el agua sino también con la presión
demográfica sobre los servicios
sanitarios
hace casi 30 años que Carolina codo
llegó como médica a el chaltén
hoy Son dos médicos y atienden a unos 50
pacientes por día pero después si pasa
algo Hay que salir Hay que salir a los
lugares cuando hay urgencias Hay que
salir Bueno yo salgo a la montaña cuando
hay rescates
hay que salir a la ruta con los
accidentes viales y para todos estamos
nosotros a Carolina codo le preocupa
especialmente el tema de la vivienda uno
no puede trabajar trabajar bien si está
viviendo en condiciones que no son
confortables no alguien que trabaja acá
nueve horas diez horas en cualquier
establecimiento turístico por ejemplo
ahora Necesitamos médicos y no hay caso
paramédicos
en abril de 2022 la falta de terrenos
llevó un grupo de vecinos a tomar este
predio en el que había una cancha de
fútbol
ahora en este momento estamos viviendo
una dos tres cuatro
cinco familias seis seis que estamos de
manera permanente acá en el lugar detrás
de la decisión hay una sucesión de
compromisos incumplidos dice ancu quien
llegó al chaltén en 2004 y se estableció
en forma definitiva en 2007 hace dos
años o dos años y medio
nos habían prometido que nos iban a
solucionar el problema eso no sucede son
harta dije Bueno yo me voy a hacer lo
que hacen en un montón de lugares que
decir y tomar un espacio
para la pequeña municipalidad del
chaltén la toma es una situación a la
vez inusual y difícil de resolver a mí
me da lástima como vecino porque también
la ordenanza dice que si vos participas
de una toma y demás ya mañana se te cae
el expediente
es digamos es todo un tema no la
posición del municipio es primero
esperar a que se expida el juez
que algún día se expedirá a ver si hay
delito o no delito
el pueblo tiene una crisis doble de
disponibilidad de tierra y de vivienda
para este segundo problema se están
llevando adelante dos proyectos de
vivienda social este de 22 unidades que
ya está en proceso de construcción en el
centro del pueblo
y otro de 86 viviendas en el entorno de
esta Laguna es algo que genera
resistencia entre vecinos por su
potencial impacto ambiental pero desde
el municipio aseguran que hicieron todos
los estudios correspondientes y que no
hay riesgos también dicen que el
proyecto seguirá adelante porque da
solución a una necesidad social sin
embargo hay Quienes no quieren vivir en
ellas muchos han construido casas trineo
que van moviendo de un lugar a otro en
predios alquilados o prestados mientras
esperan que se les dé un lugar
definitivo un terreno se estima que hay
unas 140 casas móviles en el chaltén te
los muestro desde acá estos son los
guardáis Esta es la estructura que
estaba que sobre la casa y estas son los
enganches para poder arrastrarla si el
dueño del terreno le pide dejar el lugar
tendría que sacarla no sería la primera
vez que tiene que mover la casa en la
que vive con sus dos hijos de cuando
la movimos cuando la sacamos del otro
terreno
cruje y duele porque pensás que se te va
a destruirlo es como
nada por eso por ahí soñamos en esto Si
los que ya tuvimos que moverla de que si
va a haber un nuevo una nueva
movilización de casas que ya sea para el
lugar donde se van a tener que asentar y
quedarse que vecinos como Estefanía
insistan en quedarse Más allá de todas
las dificultades también da cuenta de
que el chaltén es un lugar especial la
clave está en ese delicado entorno que
le ofrece el parque nacional que también
sufre el impacto del crecimiento del
turismo este sendero cuando se hizo
capaz que venían no sé
50 personas por día y hoy están entrando
capaz que 1000 entonces todo eso va
impactando a los costados y cada vez
vamos a encontrar
más efecto bordes los escalones que
preparamos para una actividad duran
menos porque hay más paso de la gente
también va aparejado a que cada vez hay
más basura en 1994 el chaltén fue
declarado capital Nacional del trekking
con los años esa reputación como lugar
de espectacular belleza natural lo fue
convirtiendo en un imán primero para el
turismo aventura y luego para un turismo
más general la presión sobre el
ecosistema está llevando a las
autoridades a pensar en implementar
cupos de ingreso para regular la
cantidad de personas que entran al
parque y a su vez a el chaltén Pero eso
no resuelve el problema de quienes hoy
buscan tener un terreno Y la sobrecarga
de ocupación habitacional que se da en
temporada alta existen proyectos de
expansión con la posibilidad de que el
parque nacional ceda algunas nuevas
hectáreas o incluso crear un pueblo
satélite a pocos kilómetros son todos
planes que necesitan sortear complejas
in burocráticas todavía sin plazos
concretos Mientras tanto ancud dice que
haber tomado el terreno fue su último
intento para quedarse en el chaltén dije
si me sacan de acá es porque tengo que
entender que bueno nos divorciamos con
el lugar
cuando cae la noche un poco más abajo en
el pueblo en su casilla rodante Marian
invita a otra madre que se quedó sin
alojamiento a vivir unos días con ella y
su hija se quedan a dormir acá y así
vamos a seguir compartiendo un poco la
casa
este con la espera de que las chicas
puedan resolver el tema habitacional a
la brevedad Mientras tanto el pueblo
persigue soluciones para que la
saturación no termine dañando este lugar
único en el mundo un paraíso de montaña
en el que algunos se preguntan un
paraíso Sí pero para quién
estamos de vuelta con natalio cosoy
autor del reportero que acabamos de ver
natalio ha cambiado el chaltén desde que
realizó el reportaje la situación se
mantiene igual o ha empeorado
nosotros estuvimos al inicio de la
temporada de la temporada comienza en
octubre noviembre y se extiende más o
menos hasta marzo en invierno en general
no hay tanta actividades como decía un
lugar muy muy remoto y era el inicio de
la temporada y sabía bastante turismo ya
había dificultades de vivienda ya había
presencia de grupos bastante grande en
algunas zonas del Parque Nacional de los
senderos esa presión también sobre el
entorno natural que existe en el chaltén
pero nos estuvimos comunicando en estos
días con habitantes del lugar y los
dicen que como esperaban las situaciones
más difícil Por qué Porque hay más
presión sobre los servicios la provisión
de agua la electricidad Y por supuesto
también la vivienda hay una escena en el
reportaje de una toma de tierras por un
grupo de habitantes que reclaman para
tener sus propias tierras para tener el
lugar donde vivir esa toma continúa nos
nos han comentado y las dificultades
continúan de hecho hubo recientemente
una protesta de personal el centro
sanitario del centro de salud del lugar
justamente por la problemática de la
vivienda Gracias natalio hasta aquí
reporteros en la semana Recuerda que
para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web
trans24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]